IT IS NOW TIME FOR HASHTAG WARS.
>> GUYS THE NEW BATMAN VERSUS
SUPERMAN MOVIE WAS GIVEN A NAME
TODAY AND THE TITLE IS BATMAN
VERSUS SUPERMAN.
DAWN OF JUSTICE.
I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS,
BUT WE THOUGHT WE COULD BEAT
THAT, SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAGS IS
#BETTERBATMANSUPERMAN.
>> BATMAN VERSUS SUPERMAN
VERSUS STUBBORN KITCHEN MILDEW
BATMAN AND SUPERMAN GO TO WHITE
CASTLE , SOME SOME DIFFERENT
ONES WE CAN DO.
60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, GO.
>> MOSHE KASHER.
>> TIGHTS, CAMERA, ACTION.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> MATT JONES.
>> FOUR BATMANS AND A FUNERAL.
>> YES.
POINTS.
WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> TYLER PERRY PRESENTS
BATMADIEA VERSUS SUPERMADIEA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: MATT JONES.
>> "TITANIC"... WASTE OF TALENT
AND RESOURCES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> TO BATMAN, THANKS FOR
EVERYTHING JULIE NUMAR.
>> Chris: GOOD TIE-IN TO THE
CLASSIC.
MOSHE KASHER.
>> AT LEAST OUR DIRECTOR DIDN'T
MOLEST ANYONE.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT.
I GOTTA GIVE YOU POINTS.
YES.
MATT.
>> HOW TO LOSE AN AUDIENCE IN
TEN MOVIES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WOW, MATT JONES AGAIN, WOW.
>> OH, YES.
(BLEEP)!
>> I AM GETTING (BLEEP)ED!
>> OKAY.
>> BATMAN RETURNS AND THEN
BEGINS AND THEN WE ALL LOSE
INTEREST.
>> Chris: YES. OKAY, POINTS.
WHITNEY, WHITNEY.
>> BATMAN VERSUS SUPERMAN VERSUS
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION.
>> Chris: YES! POINTS. MOSHE
KASHER.
>> SOLANGE VERSUS HOVA, THE
DARK KNOWLES RISES.